this video is sponsored by nordvpn
Science Fiction and Fantasy are
sub-genres of fiction where your
imagination can go absolutely wild where
authors Can Dream up whatever
unbelievable stuff they please put it on
paper and have absolutely no one
question it as long as it's internally
consistent however there is one thing
even the most imaginative authors
usually can get away from that is having
capitalism be their world's dominant
economic system no matter how Wild and
out there their fictional world is if
there is a modern or near modern
economic system it will most likely be
capitalism
only money this phenomenon is commonly
referred to as capitalist realism the
unconscious acceptance that capitalism
is the end of economic history this is
it we've reached the final form of
Economics there are no better
Alternatives all we can do is make Minor
Adjustments to perfect it therefore even
the wildest fictional world will
obviously operate under capitalism
because there's just no other way you
get the idea but there is something else
next to capitalist realism just as
pervasive yet rarely talked about namely
automobile a realism our inability to
imagine Our lives our cities our world
without cars now don't get me wrong
cards can be very useful and in the
countryside they will probably always be
with us however the majority of the
planet lives in cities with the share of
urban dwellers constantly increasing and
in cities cars should not be necessary
or even wanted for our everyday lives in
most major cities of most developed
countries it's already completely
possible to live car free however when
streets are reconstructed or newly built
they still look like this with the
majority of space devoted to cars
despite drivers usually being the
minority in the traffic mix gotta have
space for those metal boxes for the past
couple of years though an interesting
phenomenon has been emerging young
people are waiting longer and longer to
get their driver's licenses fewer of
them actually end up getting it and yet
fewer will actually own a car why is
this happening do young people just have
different preferences have ever benefits
and planners succeeded in incentivizing
the core free lifestyle or is it just
sheer economics does this all mean we're
nearing the end of the automobile era
that's what we're going to find out
after a healthy dose of Internet realism
isn't it weird how we've also taking
granted the lack of privacy in the
digital era like Harrier Carr will soon
be taking DNA samples from you to be
overlaid with a 5 trillion Point
behavioral model of you calculated by a
supercomputer so that Amazon can
recommend you the correct spatula well
now thanks to nordvpn the sponsor of
this video you can keep yourself safe in
this increasingly unsafe digital
landscape nordvpn's virtual private
network service helps you stay Anonymous
on the internet hides your physical
location and encrypts your personal data
available both for Android iOS and PC
nordvpn is the number one VPN provider
on the market its most popular feature
is of course the elimination of region
blocks as someone living in Europe I'm
still doomed to use Emerald boys Bird
app but with nordvpn I have access to
sites like Instagram threads where I
register with the throwaway email
address so that the zoc won't be able to
harvest my personal data in the process
I also find vpns useful when using the
Wi-Fi connection on board of trains
especially if there is some sort of
limit on usage not to mention potential
privacy concerns in addition to its
virtual private network service nordvpn
also has a data breach scanner feature
and a safe encrypted the online storage
service called nordlocker to get
nordvpn's two-year plan plus 4 months
free use my link nordvpn.com item
something which you'll also find in the
description subscribing is risk-free as
you will also get a 30-day money-back
guarantee big thanks to nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video so what is
happening with young people to cause
their declining demand for cars and
driver's licenses is it just different
preferences have they gone past
automobile realism is it proper planning
that incentivizes core free lifestyle or
is it just sheer economics and what does
this mean for the future up until the
21st century getting a driver's license
and buying a car were considered a
write-off passage for young people a
symbol of true Independence where they
no longer have to rely on the mummy taxi
to get to places this idea was most
prevalent in the US from the 1950s and
60s especially newly built course
Centric Suburbia it's the image of 1970s
cool kids zooming down the freeway in a
convertible with disco music blaring
riding into the California Sunset this
was the ideal anyway but then the bills
came in fuel Insurance servicing loan
payments or local traffic jam again
sitting in your shiny car stewing for
two hours in traffic every single day
for the rest of your productive life
doesn't sound so good does it ever since
we reached Peak automobile when
literally everyone started driving
everywhere driving went from something
cool and a symbol of freedom to a money
sink and a chore also yet another cause
for climate change so our young people
turning away from Cars due to finding it
a burden a chore or even immoral well
there's many to all of these for example
statistically speaking young people are
more concerned with climate change
understandably zero they will have to
live with the consequences after all
which we are starting to see already
major fires all over the place natural
disasters Florida is going underwater
there was even a tornado in the Czech
Republic some time ago he'd level the
whole village it was pretty terrifying
meanwhile the Republican candidates
debate not only did most candidates not
believe the existence or severity of
climate change evil Barack Obama without
the Charisma went further acknowledged
its existence and said it's actually a
good thing so it's understandable how
some young people might look at all that
and decide AI they don't want to
contribute to this Insanity thereby
opting for a core for your lifestyle
however this cannot be the answer or at
least not the whole answer if a commute
takes half an hour by car and two hours
by public transit 99 of people will opt
for the car to leave car free or at
least to de-prioritize it in your life
you'll need proper incentives such as
human friendly urban planning cities
where most things you need are within
walking distance easily accessible on
foot by bike or quality public transit
this is how we used to build our cities
until our political Elite called the
disease called core brain and now
everything has to be planted on metal
boxes because we but most their leaders
cannot imagine our world without cars
automobile realism in practice however a
growing number of activists and even
politicians are recognizing this problem
and change is happening though places
like the city of Hawaii top Republic
have adopted more unique approaches to
keep up with the times in front of this
children home for example where cars
used to take up half the sidewalk the
leadership of avijov decided to improve
the area by turning the entire sidewalk
into a parking lot thereby gaining 11
new parking spaces at the measly cost of
giving a hundred children walk on the
road to school in active traffic Czech
Republic
now you know a little bit what it's like
will you come
meanwhile in Western Europe thankfully
politicians aren't usually trying to
turn their cities into open air parking
lots even the US and Canada have had a
number of positive examples recently
there are new bike Lanes Transit lines
Highway removals even in many places the
trend is definitely positive it seems
like at least in the developed world we
are past Peak automobile the hegemony of
course is slowly ending that's not to
say we cannot backslide therefore we
should always push for more positive
changes even if we are 99 there we must
push for the remaining one percent of
all the same human-centric urban
planning really does help direct people
especially young people from a
core-centric lifestyle to a core 3-1 as
soon as roads aren't deadly for cyclists
for example and there is quality safe
infrastructure for them lots of people
will reconsider sitting inside the metal
box and go car free or at least Less Car
centered but many people still won't
take Amsterdam for example the city with
one of the best if not the best cycling
infrastructure on the planet if there is
a city where it's possible to live car
free it's Amsterdam I think we can all
agree because we all watch not just
bikes videos but even in Amsterdam many
people just won't go car free to quote
the man himself this is about the time
the driving apologist will chime in
claiming that all of these people have
to drive because they have no other
choice and need a car for some reason
thankfully the NRC actually stopped and
asked people why they were driving into
the city center were they all bringing
their poor disabled mothers out to the
canals for a sunny Sunday
no
they were just driving because that's
what they felt like doing one group said
they were at the Amsterdam Rye
Convention Center a place with one of
the best park and ride garages in the
entire city and a direct metro line that
literally brings you right to this
location within five minutes instead
they sat in traffic for an hour and a
half to get here there was only one guy
they interviewed who really needed to
drive because he was helping his son
move into a new apartment of course he
had to sit in traffic that shouldn't
have even been there if these people had
just taken the Metro like everyone else
so there as long as it's possible to
live a core-centric life many people
will just do it defying Common Sense the
only thing left to influence their
preferences is economics money
when young people refuse to drive own a
car or even get a driver's license
changing preferences environmental
concerns and better Alternatives
definitely play a role however at the
end of the day the biggest reason for
young people going car free is sheer
economics even though cars didn't get
that much more expensive the cost of
living is vastly higher and salaries
especially for young people are just not
keeping up because of that it's much
harder to afford and maintain a car so
young people are naturally looking for
Alternatives some people might find this
disappointing the decrease is not due to
a revelation by young people about the
negative effects of mass motorization
not only anyway at the end of the day
it's mostly just called hard finances
instead of despairing though if you like
me would like to see a less
score-oriented future we should use this
momentum to get as far away from Pico
automobile as possible to set these
positive changes into stone by forcing
our cities to adapt and rebuild along
the core free lifestyle instead of the
core Centric one in practice this means
always voting in local elections for the
party that promises the most human
friendly changes and that has a chance
of getting its Representatives into the
city government and if all parties are
bad vote for the least bad option
chances are the worst option already has
an army of pensioners voting for them so
if you don't vote you'll get the worst
option automatically if you do vote
however you might get the less bad
option which is still better than the
worst it's important to take every
chance not just at making things better
but at making things less worse if
needed streets only get torn up and
rebuilt once every 30 years if that so
we only get one shot at making
meaningful changes to a given public
space so we better make sure we maximize
positive changes or if that's not an
option that we minimize negative changes
for example on a more personal note I
get a lot of criticism for telling
people to vote for the German green
party I was told the greens are not
great they are not perfect and they did
bad things in the past Etc well
congratulations in the last local
election in Berlin less people showed up
to vote for the greens so the
conservatives got into Power whose first
enacted measure was to immediately put
all bike path projects on hold and then
try and erase some existing bike paths
the greens aren't perfect but they're
still a lot better than the alternative
and if you want to treat politics like a
purity test and empty virtue know where
he refused to vote for the lesser of two
evils because a political party has to
be a perfect representation of all your
important inner values congratulations
for your incisive political insight and
mature Behavior you'll get to be the
smuggish person to die under the wheels
of a pickup truck on the side of the
road that used to be a bike lane so yeah
politics is always a lesser of two
Evil's game and now that we seem to be
passing Peak automobile it is our job to
make the most of the situation via
strategic voting a future of calm safe
human-centric core free cities is
definitely possible and it seems like
we're moving towards their future at
least young people are however it is and
it will continue to be an uphill battle
it will never just happen on its own as
the car has some powerful friends in the
developed World billions are spent on
lobbying for core synthesm ever wondered
why all those far right people suddenly
started protesting 15-minute series of
all things calling it communism
surveillance dystopia thinking people
will be confined to their neighborhoods
or something this was an archboard and
astroturfing meaning fake Grassroots
campaign by the fossil fuel industry wow
do you think they would do that try to
sabotage a project that represents a
threat to the profit margins we
discussed this issue at length on the
urbanist agenda podcast with not just
bikes by the way feel free to check it
out the link is below in summary in the
fight for more livable and human-centric
cities we seem to have gained some
Headway via young people becoming more
car free mostly due to economic
circumstances and if we want to get as
far away from possible from the
corporate car-centric dystopia like
Houston to make sure we really are past
Peak automobile and to finally break
free of automobile realism we must make
sure that these positive changes are
made permanent and we can do that by
voting for the party or parties in local
elections that aren't in the pocket of
core companies and that want to take
public space away from metal boxes and
give it back to the people or if that
doesn't work then just the lesser of two
evils simple as that and I thank you for
watching if you like my content consider
supporting me on patreon link in the
description and I'll be seeing you next
time
foreign
[Music]